really
last isn't really a game of skill and as
it turns out that makes sense you're not
a cop or a soldier or a genetically
enhanced superhero you're just a
reporter and as a reporter you don't
possess many skills with which you can
fend off the hulking brutes knife
wielding stalkers and other homicidal
maniacs who lurk the halls of the
dilapidated mount massive asylum
you can't shoot them or punch them or
rip pipes from the walls to power them
with you can only run and hide you're
always in danger and when that danger is
nipping at your heels and all you can do
is flee desperately hoping to shake off
your pursuer outlast is a terrifying
roller coaster ride
hurricane coming back
unfortunately the pacing stumbles it a
few instances when outlast stops
coasting forward on its own momentum and
requires you to go hunting for the track
yourself but these are small setbacks in
what is usually a deeply unsettling
experience drawn by an anonymous tip you
come to Mount massive to investigate
allegations that an unscrupulous
corporation is doing horrible things to
mental patients in the pursuit of
profits you move through Mount massive
in first-person and you're waiting
movements make you feel physically
grounded in the environment and what an
environment it is Mount massive is
supposed to be a place with a long dark
history and as you make your way through
it
you come to believe that it has been
home to many Horrors over the decades
you can almost feel the damp moldy air
infesting your lungs and every shadowy
room fills you with apprehension because
you never know when someone might be
lying in wait to leap out at you there
are plenty of effective jump scares in
outlast but they don't feel cheap and
opportunistic the atmosphere of Mount
massive is so cohesive and so convincing
that the horror is lurking in wait for
you there feel right at home in its
pervasive darkness luckily you can
penetrate that darkness with your trusty
camcorders night vision which lets you
see your immediate surroundings but
doesn't make them any less terrifying
bathing objects in an artificial green
glow and doing nothing to dispel the
darkness mount massive scrum blowing
walls and blood-stained floors
successfully create the illusion that
you're in a once functioning facility
where unspeakable horrors have occurred
but the path you must take through the
asylum is rigidly linear you might
occasionally venture off of your narrow
route a bit to find batteries to power
your camcorders night vision or
documents that shed a bit of light on
what's taking place at the asylum but
you won't get far
there's only ever one way forward and as
you bump up against the game's
restrictive nature you're reminded that
you're in a video game after all
one design to usher you from one
terrifying situation to the next there's
nothing wrong with that when the
situations are effective and in outlast
they usually are your hunted through
much of Mount massive by a massive man
who won't hesitate to rip your heart
right out of your chest if he gets his
hands on you seeing his silhouette in
the darkness ahead or hearing his heavy
footfall somewhere nearby
are enough to make your pulse quickened
since you know you have no recourse
against him but to flee and to cower
when he does spot you and he will you
can only run hoping that you might shake
him off by finding a locker to hide in
or a bed to slide under
he's so threatening that in these
situations your own breathing might
become as ragged as the shallow
breathing of your character but outlast
runs into a bit of a problem your
encounters with the hulking brute and
the other homicidal denizens of Mount
massive are terrifying because your
opponents are so lethal and because you
can't defend yourself against them but
when you fail to elude them and you need
a grisly demise and then you have to
face the same situation for a second or
third or fourth time the tension
dissipates like you're watching a scene
in a horror movie you've seen before and
you know exactly when the killer is
going to strike when you need to repeat
scenarios outlast gameplay takes on a
rote feeling of trial and error you know
that what you did last time didn't work
so you try something else until you find
an approach that does work but in the
end outlast few weak moments are
overshadowed by the effectiveness with
which it so often gets inside your head
and scares the hell out of you you
sometimes end up feeling like you're
just going through the motions the game
requires you to go through but when the
ride is as well-designed as this the
best thing to do is just get in and hold
on tight
little fake
you